[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce numéro spécial de
skimac consacré à la sécurité pourquoi
la sécurité bien parce que c'est un
impératif pour la réussite de grands
événements dont particulièrement les
Jeux Olympiques vous savez que plusieurs
grandes épreuves seront organisées sur
ce territoire on commence tout de suite
avec un retour d'expérience le 21
septembre dernier sur la colline des
lancour était organiser une sorte de
répétition générale de l'épreuve de VTT
il s'agissait de tester la qualité du
terrain la qualité de l'accueil des
transports mais aussi de la sécurité et
bien on tire tout de suite le bilan sur
cette sécurité avec le commissaire
bougeois commissaire de la police
nationale à
hencour ce test event de la colline des
lancour avec plusieurs milliers de
spectateurs qui étaient prévus nous a
permis de roder des aspects de
sécurisation de flux indispensable pour
les Jeux Olympiques puisque les flux
sont très
importants
[Musique]
un point assez central sur ce Test Event
c'est se préparer à travailler de façon
partenariale on met en place des
cellules de coordination sous l'autorité
du corps préfectoral qui rassemble
l'ensemble des acteurs là on avait par
exemple le SAMU les militaires de
l'opération Sentinel la police nationale
et les acteurs du territoire la mairie
Saint-Quentin en
Yveline
par exemple on a pu tester un appui
drone aérien grâce à l'unité police
nationale drone qui était positionné
tout en haut de la colline ce qui nous a
permis d'avoir des images de l'ensemble
de l'épreuve et aussi des fluxs aux
abords ça c'est vraiment une évolution
technologique et un appui indispensable
qui va être très largement déployé pour
les Jeux Olympiques
[Musique]
2024 c'est aussi préparation pour nous
pour les autres épreuves qui vont se
dérouler sur le territoire notamment le
vélo sur piste le BMX le vélo sur route
ainsi que le golf sans oublier aussi le
village olympique qui sera implanté dans
la Base de Loisirs de
Saint-Quentin la recherche l'innovation
et la sécurité sont intimement liés on
va en avoir un exemple concret avec Yan
cruza président de l'apcore l'apcore
c'est une start-up qui a été incubée
d'ailleurs à 50 ans en Eveline et qui a
mis au point des portiques nouvelle
génération nouvelle génération pourquoi
parce qu'il fluidifie l'accès du public
aux grands événements on vous les
présente et on en parle avec Yan
[Musique]
cruza je suis à la base un ancien
fonctionnaire de police plus de 20 ans
de carrière j'ai eu la chance de
travailler même au groupe de sécurité du
président de la République et suite aux
attentats de 2016-207 qu'on se rappelle
à l'époque nous nous retrouvion à
l'entrée d'événement et on avait
énormément de zone d'attente de goulot
d'étranglement l'effet anentonnoir comme
on l'appelle et donc à haut
risque le laboine lui va permettre de
pouvoir accueillir du public en masse
jusqu'à 3500 personnes à l'heure il
faudrait des dispositif humain très
important l'idée étant de pouvoir
principalement fluidifier les flux mais
aujourd'hui aussi de pouvoir répondre à
une vraie problématique qui est la
problématique des recrutements en
matière d'agent de sécurité on retrouve
aujourd'hui une vraie pénurie d'agents
de sécurité sur les territoires et
surtout à l'proche des
[Musique]
GI les téléphones les ceintures les
pores-clés ça ça passe naturellement
c'est pas comme un portique lambda qui
va sonner en permanence et pour lequel
vous allez devoir enlever votre ceinture
et cetera là le portique lui a analysé
le fait que ce que vous portiez sur vous
n'était pas dangereux par contre dès que
vous allez être porteur d'une arme de PO
une arme longue d'une arme blanche ou
même de certaines densités de type
explosif auou cocktail Molotov et pour
2024 les fumigènes qui sont énormément
attendus par les stades vous serez
immédiatement détecté avec un code
couleur et qui va être immédiatement
zonalisé centralisé sur une zone de
votre corps et qui va permettre une
levée de doute pour l'agent de sécurité
derrière plus efficace et plus
[Musique]
rapide nous serions en capacité de
suivre la flamme olympique sur tout son
parcours en France c'està-dire dans
chaque ville en espace de 15 minutes on
ouvre le module le public passe il est
contrôlé 2 he après on reprend on prend
la route on va dans la prochaine ville
s'il fallait faire ça sur des
technologies complètement cousu ça
serait beaucoup trop
long ski cube l'incubateur de 50 Evelin
nous a accueilli pendant 2 ans et nous a
formé de façon à pouvoir nous
accompagner dans le développement du
produit mais aussi dans le développement
de l'équipe et de la structuration de
l'entreprise en
elle-même la sécurité donc un enjeu
majeur pour la réussite des Jeux
Olympiques songez que dans les semaines
et dans les mois qui viennent il va
falloir recruter 15000 agents de
sécurité pour l'ensemble des Jeux
Olympiques et bien justement sur ce
territoire le 21 novembre prochain au
Vélodrome est organisé une grande
opération de recrutement en vue des Jeux
Olympiques il y aura beaucoup
d'entreprises de sécurité comme ESP
c'està-dire Europe sécurité protection
et bien justement Yatera Damba le
président de ESP nous dit ce qu'il
attend de cette journée
en 2009 j'étais salarié de la société
euros surté protection cette société
rencontrit de grosses difficultés
financières par un concours de
circonstant je me suis retrouvé dans les
bureaux des dirigeants à entendre qu'ils
allaient fermer cette entreprise à
partir de là donc j'ai repris
l'entreprise on avait une dizaine de
salariés aujourd'hui ESP donc a un peu
plus de 400
salariés j'ai recruté deux personnes qui
vont s'occuper exclusivement du
recrutement pour Paris 2024 on a un
besoin d'à peu près 1500
[Musique]
agents le 21 novembre pourô l'emploi
l'agglomération de 51 en yeline et Paris
2024 organise un grand événement ici au
Vélodrome on pourra vous aider à faire
les démarches pour pouvoir passer les
formations aujourd'hui l'État en fait a
sorti un diplôme qui s'appelle le ccup
grands événements donc ça vous permet de
pouvoir passer c'est la formation
d'agent de sécurité en 3 semaines
seulement donc pour les jeunes étudiants
cette formation est rémunérée après pour
faire une formation un peu plus globale
un peu plus longue pour pouvoir
travailler vraiment faire une carrière
là on parle d'une formation de 5
semaines ce qu'on attend d'un agent de
sécurité c'est qu'il soit bien sûr qu'
qu'il ait un self contrôle qui puisse
avoir une bonne perception des choses
qui l'entourent on a un regard partout
on doit être tout le temps à l'affu de
de beaucoup de choses ça malheureusement
les les personnes ne le voient pas on
demande aussi à ce que l'agent de
sécurité soit un minima un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sportif pour pouvoir contrôler le public
il nous faut autant de femmes que
d'hommes pour aussi désamorcer des
conflits on a un grand besoin de de
femmes donc mesdames je vous invite
vraiment à à venir nous rejoindre
souvent quand on a des personne un peu
éméché ou autre le fait de de de de voir
venir une femme ça peut tout de suite
faire redescendre la tension donc à
partir de là ça nous permet de de
désamorcer quelquefois des conflits
assez
compliqués merci à tous de votre
fidélité et à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de
skimag